Okay.
So let's pick up where we left off on
Monday and we were starting to talk in
more detail about Macintyre's argument.
And um,
one of the things I want to reserve pro
in centrally on today is his account of
human psychology or what used
to be called human nature. Um,
and that differs importantly from every
account of human psychology we've looked
at thus far, um, for a number of reasons.
And I'm going to spell them
out in a little bit more
detail then we talked about
on Monday.
Um,
basically it is an error,
the telian conception of the structure
of human psychology and that has a number
of features to it.
One is that I mentioned to you that we
think of human beings as teleological
creatures.
We are purpose of creatures.
We always want to know what
the point of an activity is.
Um,
now if you go back to Aristotle,
Aristotle held the view that
while we are purpose of creatures,
we only reason about the
means to achieve our goals,
not the goals themselves.
For Aristotle,
Aristotles conception of virtue,
the virtues,
the virtues were given for all time.
And he had his list of the virtues,
which you can find if you go back
and read the Nica McKeon ethics.
They're things like a courage,
honesty and various other,
uh, perhaps debatable, perhaps not.
But in any event, in, in
Aristotle scheme of things, um,
what we reasoned about is the
means to achieve the virtues,
not the virtues themselves and are going
to come back to that because one of the
respects in which macintyre differs
from Aristotle is that he wants to say,
um,
the virtues.
He wants to at least go this far with the,
the enlightenment thinkers.
He wants to say that what counts
as a virtue is to some extent,
uh,
up for debate just to what extent
and how we debated are things,
things that I'll come back to.
But,
but the more important point is that this,
as,
as an account of the
structure of human psychology,
we need to know what the point is we have,
we have goals,
we have purposes.
When those purposes are met,
we're happy and fulfilled
when they're not met.
We're frustrated and
unsatisfied and discontented.
Um,
just to give you a somewhat
different perspective on this,
this approach to thinking
about human psychology.
I would say that the
other influential Eris,
the Tyrian about time besides Alister
Mcintyre is the Nobel prize winning
economist Amartya Sen,
um,
who develops the idea of
human potentiality as the
core notion that we are,
we are people who have potential.
And unless we realize our potential,
we're going to be in some
basic sense in complete.
I'm not fulfilled,
not happy human beings.
And so in incense account
of justice, which, uh,
I wish we had time to talk about
in this course. Uh, but we don't,
it's an analogous that he's an economist,
not a philosopher.
So he's brings the considerations
of an economist to this question.
But it's the same question of human beings
who have a certain kind of potential
that has to be realized in
order for them to be fulfilled.
Uh,
okay.
In the, in the teleological, uh, capacity,
it ha that has to occur. And so, um,
with Mcintyre too,
it's this idea of the structure of
human psychology being goal directed.
Um, and we'll get, we'll get
into the content later. But,
so that's the first thing.
And then the second was that are um,
yeah,
behavior is in a very
fundamental way other directed.
So just again by way of a comparison,
think back to the
okay.
Assumptions about other directedness in
previous thinkers who we have considered
in the scores when we focused
on the utilitarian tradition,
um, we saw a paypal as
essentially self referential.
Remember Ronald Reagan's famous question
in 1984 are you better off than you
were four years ago?
Was a self referential question.
Are you better off than
you were four years ago?
All you have to look at is how you were
fairing four years ago and how you're
fairing now.
And Ask yourself that question.
Other people don't enter into it at all.
Then when we considered Marxism,
we came to think about other directed
conceptions of human psychology in that
Mark's made our welfare critically
reliant on what others get.
Um, and so, um,
he said that your perception of whether
you're exploited turns upon what your
employer gets.
I mean,
we talked about this in some depth and
concluded that Mark's was half right in
that people are often other
directed in that that sense of,
of what they get,
their sense of whether what they get is
legitimate is dependent on what others
get.
But what he was wrong about
was that people tend to
compare themselves to people
who are similarly situated
in the socioeconomic order.
So auto workers compared
themselves maybe to um,
uh,
steel workers but not to auto executives
and they don't make those kinds of
global comparisons.
Nonetheless,
there is something to this idea that
people's conception of their welfare is
connected to what others get.
And so relative inequalities matter simply
from the perspective of your feeling
of uh,
how well off you are.
And you can tell yourself any number
of stories to make this point. You the,
the, the telling why not quite
often I think is, you know,
you give a child a glass of orange juice
that's half full and he's very happy
and then you get his sister one that's
completely fall and he immediately
becomes unhappy because what matters to
him is the relative difference and not
what he has in his glass.
So that's a notion of other directed.
And of course you can take this notion
of other directed further still by
linking your utility not to just one,
just to what other people get,
but to actually what
other people experience.
And this is the concept of other direct,
uh,
this is the concept of
interdependent utility, uh, as it,
as it gets referred to in the literature.
And the examples here are things like,
uh,
a parent,
um,
taking pleasure in their child's success
and feeling pain at their child's lack
of success.
One of the famous a one
line has that parents, uh,
will resonate with is you can only be
as happy as your least happy child.
So if your kids are unhappy,
then you're miserable.
That's the notion of
interdependent utility.
Your happiness is conditioned on what,
on what others get.
But Not Justin in making us a relative
judgment with the orange juice,
Chi kind of a case.
But your happiness becomes
dependent on what people are,
the actually themselves experience tense,
interdependent utility.
And those are the example
of the child's happiness.
Making the parent or the child success,
making the parent happy is an
interdependent, positive utility.
But of course there are interdependent
negative utilities as well as when a or a
sadist or rapist utility goes up as a
byproduct of their victims utility going
down. Again, that's interdependent,
negative utility. And it's,
it's the mirror image of interdependent,
positive utility.
The Aristotelian conception,
that error that Macintyre embraces takes
into dependent utilities a step further
even than that though in that it's not
just that your happiness or success
satisfaction or fulfillment
is conditioned upon,
um,
the experience of others,
but it's the experience of
others as it relates to you.
It's the others' experience of you,
if you like.
And so a good example of this actually
comes from Hegel's phenomenology where he
talks about, um, the,
this dialectic between the master and
the slave as being inherently unstable.
Um,
but it's not just unstable because the
slave is going to find it unsatisfactory.
Um, it's, it's,
it's unstable because the master
will find it unsatisfactory.
Hagle says in the phenomenology that
what we want most fundamentally is
recognition from others,
but it can't be recognition from
others that we don't respect.
So it's the recognition of a slave saying,
yes,
Monster Know Mazda is not going to be
satisfactory or fail failing to you.
What you want is recognition from
an equal or perhaps a superior,
but you want recognition from somebody
who's recognition can be valuable to you
to source of feeling valued
by somebody you value.
So it's, it takes this idea, as I
said, an interdependent utility,
even a step further because it,
it's now goes to the,
the reciprocal relationship
between you and the other person.
And that is the idea of practices.
That is the,
it's a sort of neo regalian idea in,
in this particular sense
that informs Makin dies.
I notion of a practice. When I gave you
the example on Monday, I said, you know,
if I build sheds and write books,
it's not any,
it's not enough for me to
have the carpenters say, oh,
you wrote a good book. And uh, and
the academic side, that's an I shed.
I want the carpenter does
say that's a good shit.
And the people who know about writing
books to us to say this is a good book,
right? That's the ocean, not the
notion of he's a pitcher's pitcher.
You want recognition from people for home.
You have is steam at
the relevant activity.
So this is a different,
again view of the structure
of human psychology.
All of these different
theories are predicated on
some account of the structure
of human psychology.
And indeed,
I think that one thing you
should be seeing as we move
through and examine these
different arguments is that every
political theory has an account of human
psychology and an account of
how the world operates causally.
And you need to sometimes
dig to get them out. Um, but,
but one of the ways in which you should
evaluate them is you should ask yourself,
what is the theory of
human psychology driving?
This doesn't make sense.
Is it true to my own experience or not?
And if not,
why not though?
That's one question.
And then the second is what are the
assumptions about how the world works
causally? And I'll come back to
those in relation to Mcintyre again,
but you could go through all the thinkers
we've considered and find assumptions
or arguments about those two things.
And they provide a very good comparative
reference point for thinking about how
they stack up against one another.
As we've just seen as we went from
the utilitarian to the Marxian,
uh, to the, uh, different
variants of, of other referential,
um, human, uh, assumptions
about human psychology.
So this is,
this is the Mcintyre approach that
what we really want out of life is,
is steam from people who we esteem
and that operates through these,
these con, this, these
practices as he describes them.
And,
um,
this is just a summary Statement
of what I've already told you.
He where he says virtues as he describes
them are embedded in pro practices.
It belongs to the concept of a practice.
As I've, as I have outlined it,
and as we all familiar with
it in our actual lives,
whether we are painters or physicists or
quarterbacks were indeed just lovers of
good painting or first rate
experiments or a wealth thrown pass,
that it's goods can only be achieved
by subordinating ourselves within the
practice in our relationships
to other practitioners,
we have to learn to recognize
what is due to whom.
We have to be prepared to take whatever
self endangering risks or demanded along
the way.
And we have to listen carefully to what
we are told about our own inadequacies
and to reply with the same
carefulness for the facts.
So this is the notion that I translated
into the proposition that when you walk
into your first Yell College course,
you don't say,
look around and say to the people next
to you, how should we run this courts?
What should we agree to? On the
contrary, what you do is say,
what is the practice? What are
the norms? What are the rules?
How do I do well here and
what's expected of me?
How will I know if I'm doing well?
It might occur to you much
later on to say, you know,
that Washington a very well run a course.
It could have been run better if that,
if this,
that and the other.
So you can criticize and Makin
I'll come back to that point later.
Um,
but you can only criticize on the basis
of first having internalized the norms
governing the practice,
right?
You don't criticize somebody's pitching
style in major league baseball until
you've learned a lot about
pitching or maybe you do,
you sit there and throw your beer can
at the screener or terrible, but, uh,
it's not the form of criticism he
is going to care about. Right? Uh,
and that's the point.
And it's not likely to be the
criticism that makes any difference.
So rather than the,
the voluntary agent being
at the center of things,
which is the,
the workmanship story,
this anti enlightenment
[inaudible] enlightenment story,
subordinates the
individual to the practice,
to the group, to the inherited
system of norms and values.
And if you want a contemporary
reference point, just,
just again to sharpen the comparison
here compared the car Tz idea,
which puts the willing agent at the
center of the universe with the um,
[inaudible],
which is a kind of African religion,
which does the contrarian thing
instead of I think therefore I am,
it's,
I am because we are and
since we are therefore I am.
So it's this idea of
subordinating yourself two and
a half and inherited system
of norms of prion and practices
in which you find yourself not,
which you created in he will
hypothetically might have created,
but where the in which you find
yourself. So this is, this is,
this is a fundamental difference.
It doesn't get more
fundamental than this I think.
Because as you've seen in every variant
of enlightenment thinking it's the will,
the willing creative agent that is
that the ultimate bottom of the heap.
And here it's not. It's the
subordinated individual, uh,
and the community to which the community
or the practice or the tradition to
which the person is subordinated.
That is at the very bottom of the heap.
So these are,
this is really a fundamental difference.
Okay,
so features of Eris alien or we might
call it [inaudible] alien psychology.
One is we are teleological in
the sense of being purposive.
We have potential to realize and realizing
that potential is essential to our
happiness. It's not just getting
more of what gives you utility.
There's some developmental
dimension to this. Second,
the
okay,
the individual is subordinated
to a practice and that
translates into this idea
of the community becoming before
the individual in politics.
But third and in some ways for Mcintyre
story most important of all is that on
the Aristotelian scheme,
human nature is malleable,
it's plastic,
it can be shaped in different ways.
And what is so deeply misguided about
the enlightenment project from Mac and
pious point of view is that it
does not take account of this fact.
It does not take account of the fact that
human beings are malleable creatures.
Human psychology is shaped
by circumstances and
okay,
so when Russo says at the
start of the social contract,
I'm in a reason about
politics taking manners,
they are and laws as they might be.
That underscores the fact that we're so
is missing the developmental features of
human psychology in
reasoning about politics.
And it's in missing that,
that the enlightenment
project went off the rails.
So let's talk about Aristotle's
scheme and then I let,
let me just read this too,
and then I will explain it
if you haven't understood it.
He says it in his description.
We have a threefold scheme
in which human nature,
as it happens to be human nature
in its untutored or raw state,
is initially discrepant and discordant
with the precepts of ethics and needs to
be transformed by the instruction of
practical reason and experience into human
nature as it could be if it real the eyes.
It's tell us each of the
three elements of the scheme,
the conception of untutored human nature,
the conception of the precepts
of irrational ethics and
the conception of human
nature as it could be if it realizes it's
t loss requires reference to the other
two if its status and
function or to be in town.
Digable.
So his point here is if you
go back and read Aristotle,
he had a view of raw or
untutored or brute human nature,
how we are
when we are born.
Then he had an account of human beings
as they could be if they realize they're
tell us their purposes.
And then he had an account of the rules
that get you from the one to the other,
the rules, the norms that get
you from the one to the other.
And those are the rules of ethics.
So what are the rules of ethics?
The rules of ethics are those things
that get you from untutored or raw human
nature too.
The kinds of beings who realized
that tell us or purposes.
And that's why if you look at ancient
philosophers like Aristotle or Plato,
the two central features
of their political theory
that are completely absent.
When you read,
say John Rawls,
a theory of family life
and a theory of education,
it would have been bizarre
beyond imagining for Aristotle
or Plato to think you
could have a theory of politics that
didn't put a huge amount of intention to
those two things.
Think of how many people in this
room have read Plato's Republic,
at least a good number of you think,
how much of that's a book about politics.
Think how much of that is about how
to rear children and the system of
education, uh, that has to prevail,
right? Enormous amount of it.
Probably half the book.
It's nothing of that enrolls
his theory of justice, right?
On males account in on liberty.
So it's a big difference.
And the reason is,
and the same is true of Aristotle's
ethics and these other writings about
politics. Lots of attention
to education, to the family,
um,
to these things that are,
that involves shaping
this malleable plastic,
human nature so that we have a good
outcome rather than a bad outcome.
Right?
And so what,
what bugs Macintyre,
is he saying we want to
derive the rules of ethics
from human nature as it is,
as we find it.
But that's never gonna work because
the rules of ethics I design to improve
behavior,
not to simply aggregate
behavior.
And so anything we design,
anything we design that's just derived
from people as they happen to be.
It's gonna. It's gonna seem unsatisfying,
satisfying to us and satisfactory to us.
So you know, to go back to
the examples we discussed, um,
affirmative action, the ones he mentioned
at the beginning of the book, abortion,
affirmative action and so on.
Yes,
we're going to see people have different
values and therefore different.
Yeah,
uh,
views about those questions,
but they're not going to be,
they're not going to ultimately be
satisfied with just recognizing their
differences because they have inherited
a whole language of talking about ethics
that presumes these things
can be resolved. That there,
that there is it,
there is more to ethical disagreement
then just accepting the differences among
us and that at the end of the
day is why the enlightenment
project was a fool's errand.
Since this is just mere Mcintyre's more
eloquent and lucid statement of what
I've been saying to you for the last five
minutes, minutes that I'm capable of.
He says since the moral injunctions were
originally at home in a scheme in which
their purpose was to correct,
improve and educate human nature,
they are clearly not going to be such
as could be deduced from true statements
about human nature. Just
think of Bentham, he says,
we are driven by pleasure
seeking and pain avoiding.
I'm going to derive a whole system from
that right mackintosh saying that's
crazy because these moral injunctions
were designed to be at odds with human
nature. The injunctions of
morality that's understood,
they're likely to be the ones that
human nature has strong tendencies to
disobey.
Hence the 18th century moral philosophers
engaged in what was inevitably an
unsuccessful project for.
They did indeed attempt to find a rational
basis for their moral beliefs in a
particular understanding of human
nature while inheriting a set of moral
injunctions on the one hand
and a conception of human
nature. On the other hand,
which had been expressly designed
to be discrepant with each other.
They inherited incoherent fragments of
a once coherence scheme of thought and
action.
And since they did not recognize their
own peculiar historical and cultural
situation,
they could not recognize the impossible
and quixotic character of their self
appointed task.
Whether it's Ben,
I'm trying to derive maxims
of conduct from the posture,
them pleasure seeking pain
avoidance or Rousseau trying to,
um,
come up with a system of government
taking manners. They are,
and they laws his name might be or can't,
trying to see what principles
human beings as they currently are,
would affirm from every conceivable
standpoint it's Naveh gonna work.
The morality that comes out of this
kind of reasoning is going to same.
And actually we'll be unsatisfying to us.
And so we,
if you,
if you now go back and look at some of
the puzzles and conundrums we came up
with when we were considering those
different theories, Macintyre would say,
well, you shouldn't be surprised.
You shouldn't be surprised.
Um,
that object of utilitarianism puts,
uh,
allows people to take advantage
of one another in appalling ways.
And you shouldn't be surprised that
subject of utilitarianism allows people to
ignore one another in a Po
Marley appalling ways, um,
because what makes things seem
morally appalling to you? Um,
treat people with dignity. Um,
don't lie, cheat and steal.
These are maxims that,
um,
we know people have a tendency to disobey,
right? And so that's the point of them,
that to make us behave better and you're
not going to be able to derive them in
this sense from
a completely empirically
accurate description of human
beings as we find them in
the wall. So it's a, it's a kind of
secular doctrine of the fall, right?
And in Christian, in
Christian thinking, you know,
we have the fall and then
we have inadequate human
beings and the possibility of
redemption,
the possibility of redemption
through internalizing and accepting,
um, Christ as your savior. The Sec,
this is a secular version
of the fall that we have.
MMM
MMM.
Fallen the secular version of fallen
man untutored ill formed human nature.
And then we have what, what we could
be if we, we are properly formed.
And then the system of the rules of ethics
that are going to get us from the one
to the other.
And it's,
it's the virtues in within practices that,
uh,
achieving them w achieving lives lived
in accordance with them that enable us
to,
um,
realize our purposes in a good way.
And it's,
it's there the rules and norms governing
those practices that get us from a to
B.
And
the big problem with the enlightenment
philosophically is what I've just said to
you,
that they try and engage
in this quixotic task,
but in politics itself,
okay,
it's the creation of an emotive as world.
It's a creation of a world
that's separates, means from ends that
values the instrumental reasoning,
the world. You know, the business
school world written large,
the,
the world in which we make ourselves
agnostic about people's purposes and just
try to set ourselves up as the most
efficient executer of any purpose have
skills. Well travel, right?
I'm a consultant for what?
Well, whatever you need,
right?
That's,
that's what he finds politically
shocking and appalling,
but he thinks it's underpinned by
this whole philosophical scheme.
Now, Mcintyre wrote this during
the, this book came out in 1984,
which was at the height of the Cold War.
You know,
one of the points he was making
was everybody thinks the,
the,
the great battle of our time is the
confrontation between capitalism and
communism.
But for Macintyre,
you know, these are two sides of the
same coin because there they are both.
They are both
ways in which this enlightenment project
has been played out and politics and
they're both for him.
Appalling.
So when we,
you know,
I started out saying to Mcintyre,
thought of himself as a
person on the political left,
at least when he was young,
when he wrote Marxism and Christianity
and against the self images of the age
and those holy books.
But it's in a different sense.
It's not like, you know, uh,
Robert Bork said at one point in
his confirmation hearings, you,
you're already too young to
remember this, but he, uh,
they questioned him about his
changing ideological beliefs.
And at one point he said,
well,
I've always thought if you're not
a socialist before the age of 30,
you have no heart. And if you are
a socialist after the age of 30,
you have no head. Um, this
isn't macintyre, right.
He wants to say the whole
enlightenment venture,
whether it's in its capitalist or it's
socialist form is a variant of this.
Um,
yeah,
deeply muddled,
hopeless quest,
mmm.
To develop a science of politics
based on a human nature as we find it.
And so his prescriptions are
rather different. He says,
what matters at this stage
is the construction of local
forms of community with
within which civility and intellectual
and moral life can be sustained through
the new dark ages which
are already upon us.
He's not a utopian,
he's a dystopian almost.
And if the tradition of the virtues was
able to survive the horrors of the loss
dark ages, we're not entirely
without grounds for hope this time.
However, the barbarians are not
waiting beyond the frontiers.
They've already been governing
and us for quite some time.
And it is our lack of consciousness
of deaths that constitutes part of our
predicament. We're not, we
are waiting not for Godot,
but for another doubtless
very different saint benedict.
Now
people criticized McEntire
for a variety of things.
But one of the things they criticized
him for was this seems to be sort of
throwing up your hands,
uh, and saying, you know,
the whole world is terrible.
We're about to enter the new dark ages
and there's not much we can do about it
except hunkered down and hope.
MMM.
And he wrote several books that probably
the most important of which is a book
called whose justice,
which rationality in an attempt
to respond to these criticisms.
But actually on the, on the on,
I'll talk about some of that in,
in a minute on the actual
politics that flow from this.
He never had anything more to
say than this. So it's really,
it is,
it is a diagnosis without a cure.
And if you, you know, I said this was
written at the height of the Cold War.
If you look at the post
Cold War and you say,
what would macintyre say today?
Um,
it's not at all clear because he certainly
would not be a fan of militant Islam,
but it's not clear what he
would, you know, he would,
he would probably find the
spread of globalization as
just one more step in this
appalling,
a triumph of instrumental
reasoning and values.
So, uh, I think he would, he
would, uh, he would be Joe,
no less despondent. Um, and I think he's,
he's diagnosis,
this is pure speculation.
I haven't had this conversation with them,
but my guess is that his diagnosis of
militant Islam and jihadism and all of
that would be, he would just say, well,
it's, it's an inevitable undertow.
It's an inevitable reaction by the
losers from globalization against,
uh, against the, the,
the endless spread, um, of, um,
enlightenment ideas.
Uh,
I think in some ways that could be a more
interesting makin and Tyrion analysis
of China in that, in China, you know,
we see now the fusion of comment as
politics and capitalist economics,
neither of which I was any signs
of going anywhere. And so the, the,
you know, when in 1984
somebody had said, well,
capitalism and communism are
two sides of the same coin.
People would have been quite dismissive
when you think about China today.
Um, you know, it's, it's
quite thought provoking.
Okay.
So that's Macintyre in a nutshell.
Lots of, it's quite appealing. You
know, this account of human beings,
how many people that, never mind the on
realism of the pilot. How many find the,
this account of human nature plausible,
true to your own experience.
At least some, not that
money. We do, you know,
we want, we're, we're,
we're sort of lots of unrequited love,
right? We, we want to be liked. We want,
we want to be wanted and we want to be
wanted by cool people or people we think
are cool.
All right?
So that whole side of it seems right
and the notion that political morality
should somehow be an
improving thing seems right.
That it can't, you can't
just derive it from the, um,
as Russo said it,
if you take all of our
individual preferences and
add them up and get rid of the
pluses and minuses that
cancel one another out, uh,
that's maybe the general,
well, but you know,
Macintyre would say it's going to be
the lowest common denominator, right?
It's going to cater to our base instincts
and we are malleable shapeable a
improvable creatures and we're not
happy unless that actually happening.
So all of that seems right.
But on the other hand,
as I mentioned to you,
yeah,
Mcintyre makes one huge concession.
Okay.
To the way of thinking that at
least motivated the enlightenment,
which was that Aristotle was wrong
to say we don't reason about ends now
Aristotle took ends is given and said,
we only reason about means.
So the big pile,
the big challenge for Mac and
tie is to say, well, how do you,
how do you say,
okay,
and this can be put in
question as subject for debate,
but not then wind up with emotive ism.
How do you, how do you
structure, how do you put limits?
If you like on debates about ends,
which recognizes that people do in fact,
you know,
a difference between human beings and uh,
and dogs let's say,
or lions,
is that dogs in lions can't think
critically about their own ends.
They just think instrumentally about
how their ends. So really are given,
you know, dog wants to sit on a warm
couch, Elian wants to kill a buck.
And there's not no question
about that for a dog or alliance,
how you get on a warm couch without
being kicked off at by some nasty human,
uh, that's a question for a dog, but
not whether you want to be on right.
Human beings aren't like that.
Human beings are capable of thinking
critically about purposes and goals.
So we have the, we, you know,
what Macintyre wants to say is we have
the structure of an Aristotelian psyche,
but not the content we do.
We are not men. And, uh,
lions in, in that sense, we can
critically appraise how goals,
but then we can argue about them and then
we can disagree about them and we can
even have civil wars about them. Uh,
when it really gets down to it. Right?
So what do you do with the fact
that we reasoned about goals?
Okay.
That's why introduces the concept of
a practice. He says, well, it's true.
We reasoned about goals,
but we don't pluck them from nowhere.
Okay.
We're born into practices where the
goals are defined, where, you know,
the goal of chess is to get the person
checkmate with as many of their pieces on
the board as possible.
You don't say,
let's invent a board game. You say,
what are the goals of chess? Okay.
And so,
okay,
they're given by practices or communities.
And if we think about what is a
practice or a community over time,
it's a tradition,
right?
And so what he wants to say is
we are born into practices and communities
and we reproduce them into the future,
uh,
simply by living in them.
We inherit,
we live and we reproduce into the future.
So it's a little reminiscent or perhaps
even more than a little reminiscent of
Berks line about, yes, we are
a part of a social contract,
but it's a contract
among those who are dead.
Those who are living in those
who are yet to be born. Right.
And so yes, we do question, you know,
you might play chess for
law on and say, well, is it,
should it really be the goal of chess
to beat the person with as many of their
pieces on the board as possible?
Why maybe you may be getting,
getting their pieces on the way they are,
the subordinate subordinated pieces
on the way to before the check made.
It should be a goal of chess, you know,
and you could have a debate, is it,
does it take more skill to knock off
the knights and the bishops and so on in
order and then get the checkmate?
Or does it take more scale to get the
Person Checkmate with their knights and
Bishops on the board? And that could be
a debate you could have, but it's a very,
it's a contained debate. It's
a structured debate, right?
And he wants to say, our debates
about ends are always like that,
you know, think about debates
getting closer to home for Mcintyre.
I think about debates within
the Catholic church, you know,
the next generation of Catholics
doesn't say, should we have a church?
Should it be organized? Should the
bishop of Rome have a special status?
Should there be a papal infallibility?
No.
You're born into a structure
that's already there. And
then maybe you say, Whoa,
Whoa,
why is there papal infallibility?
It only, it's only relatively recent
creation. Does it make, you know?
So your questioning of vans is always
from the vantage point of somebody who's
born into an inherited tradition.
And it doesn't make sense to criticize
it from the perspective about a space.
It doesn't make sense to any of the
participants and it won't ultimately give
you any answers that will
be of any in any sense,
meaningful to you.
Right.
And so he sees traditions as the,
as the,
um,
okay.
Mechanisms through which practices
are reproduced over time. And He,
and he wants to say, yes, there is
argument about ends. We then traditions.
But it's always this kind of structured
argument that is shaped by the way in
which questions come up within traditions.
He says somewhere of course. Um, part of,
part of what it means to be a Jew is to
argue about what it means to be a Jew.
That within the Jewish tradition that
that is one of the things that people
argue about and disagree about.
But it's always going to be this bounded
structured disagreement that brings to
bear other,
other ideas within the tradition,
within the tradition on some
particular traditional plain,
if you, if for those of you who
are like philosophical jargon,
Michael Walzer wrote a book,
uh,
along comparable lines where he
talked about the idea that the,
the only effective criticism
is imminent criticism,
which is a bit like imminent for walls
is a bit like internal for Mcintyre.
If you want,
if you want to influence Catholics
to change their behavior,
you're not going to influence
them unless you appeal to values.
They embrace to norms,
they embrace to elements of the tradition
they accept and showed them how they,
um,
are undermined by the particular
thing that you are criticizing. So,
internal criticism,
imminent criticism,
not ex Cathedra criticism made,
uh,
from outside a whole system of norms
and values, practices, institutions.
Uh, you might think you're
right, but you'll know it'll,
it'll never have an effect.
Okay.
On the people you're trying to influence.
So is very much in that spirit.
We can argue and reason about ends,
but only from inside
traditions and practices.
Um, okay, we're out of time and we,
I will finish up with this and then
start talking about democracy on Monday.